so it's generally when you involve in
eating
intermediary and that's because the end
buyer wants some transference of trust
and they trust the USDA more than they
trust a buyer that a grower that they're
never going to meet and when you start
looking at Gap there are slightly
different types of Gap there's Gap
specifically for mushrooms for tomatoes
for aquaponics um and for a few other
things
um and there are certain like categories
within Gap so there's the Harvest step
or the production step uh like field
production there's the harvesting or
pack house and then there's post Harvest
handling unless I don't know about you
because I think at some point you uh
would wash your sunflower shoots which
would probably be considered post
Harvest handling since we don't wash our
Greens in any way we did not have to
comply with or fulfill or go through the
Hoops of the post Harvest like category
of requirements